into sport utility vehicles
what's the story behind the secret yale
organization skull and bones whose
membership includes both the current and
former presidents bush
in secrets of the tomb
a yale graduate and secret society
member takes us into our alma mater to
find out this talk from the yale
university bookstore in new haven
connecticut is about a half an hour
thanks um thanks very much for coming
can you hear me in the back
can you hear me now
all right this is not gonna be easy
okay um i have to say this is sort of a
weird situation for me um at my other
book reading sometimes after the event
was over a member of a secret society
it's happened with manuscript now and
it's happened with brasilias has come up
to me and talked about the book and
admitted that they were members but this
is the first time i've done a reading
where there are probably members of
skull and bones in the audience
among you right now and there are
probably members of my own secret
society among you here as well in fact
i think i recognize a few although i'm
not going to point them out for you so i
should say at the outset that
if you feel that during my talk or
during the question and answer period
i'm not being quite as forthcoming as i
might otherwise be if there weren't
members of my secret society in the
audience
email me at
secretsofthetomb.com where we can have a
private side conversation
a lot of people have asked me why i
decided to try to investigate skull and
bones and the bottom line is really that
skull and bones is an irresistible
opportunity for a reporter looking for a
challenge
here you have a secret society perhaps
the or at least one of the most infamous
secret societies in the world this is a
society with setting its headquarters is
a practically windowless building called
the tomb the tea the temple or the
boodle and it's located here at yale
uh skullenbones also owns a private
island they've owned it since the turn
of the 20th century it's about 350 miles
from new york city on the saint lawrence
river
this is also a story with characters at
any given time there are about 800
living members of skull and bones these
members in these members include people
like george w bush many other bushes
senator john kerry which could make the
presidential election of 2004
particularly interesting if it becomes
the first bones versus bones ballot
pulitzer prize-winning biographer david
mccullough is a member of skull bones as
was avril harriman henry stimson and
even steve greenberg the former deputy
commissioner of major league baseball
all of these members know to keep quiet
about the society's secrets and in fact
in 2000 when george w bush was
campaigning for presidents
the society actually sent a letter
reportedly to all members reminding them
that they had better keep quiet about
the society's secrets especially to
members of the media
this is also a story with mystery the
society is fraught with rumors secrets
and alleged conspiracies skull and bones
is said to operate a secret world
government it's rumored to be a wealthy
landowner that guarantees its members
power and financial security for life
and conspiracy theorists have managed to
pin onto skull and bones everything from
foreign policy disasters to one of my
personal favorites uh the horrors of the
dewey decimal system
[Laughter]
so with setting characters and mystery
i figured that skull and bones would be
a fun interesting and difficult story on
which to report
but of course there was more to it than
that there always is so i thought i'd
tell you a little bit more about my
reasons behind
my decision to try to investigate skull
and bones
first of all when i was at yale i
thought that secret societies were sort
of fading i thought they were on their
way out and that people my age just
didn't care so much anymore
but about a year after i graduated i
heard a revealing story
about a girl who was in my class the
class of 1998.
this was a girl who was one of the
prominent figures on campus
if there was a major activity going on
she had inevitably played some part in
organizing it and so people just assumed
that when her senior year rolled around
when she was missing from
parties dining halls and bars every
thursday and sunday night like the rest
of the secret society members that she
inevitably must have been tapped by
skull and bones or another major secret
society
well
sometime before she graduated probably
about three or four weeks beforehand her
roommate found her on a thursday night
she had not in fact been attending
secret society meetings every thursday
and sunday night instead she was hiding
in a weenie bin in the top floor of
sterling memorial library so that
everybody would think that she had been
tapped for a secret society because she
was so mortified that she had not been
as a prominent figure on campus i
thought that was kind of a telling story
another reason i was intrigued by skull
and bones was how widespread the rumors
are and how readily people tend to
accept them
here's an anecdote from the book dealing
with that this actually happened to me
about a year and a half ago when i
visited yale for an alumni convention
george bush was one of the featured
speakers that weekend so i had decided
that i was going to spend the afternoon
staking out the skull and bones tomb
waiting for george bush to come by and
if he walked by and tried to get into
the tomb i had it in my head that i was
going to confront him um he never came
by but
this sort of interesting scene happened
and this is an excerpt from the book
so here i am sitting in front of the
tomb
two new haven police officers pedal by
in their bicycles then circle back in
front of the skullenbones tomb where
they engage in a serious discussion
about the secret society
i interrupt
do you know if george bush has been here
yet i ask
we could tell you but then we'd have to
kill you joke's one of the officers
we haven't seen him the other one says
but he wouldn't come in the front door
or the side door he'd come in another
entrance
there aren't any other entrances i point
out
yes there are the police officer insists
he gestures to the surrounding building
street hall lc the art gallery
it's all interconnected underneath these
buildings the officer says the tunnels
lead everywhere bush could get in from
practically anywhere on campus
i look up sharply
you've been down there
how do you know that
the police officer says to me i saw the
movie
i pause incredulously to gauge whether
the man is serious
he is
there are only two entrances to this
building i have the floor plans i tell
him
how did you get them the officer gapes
well i could tell you but then i'd have
to kill you i say
the other officer nearly falls off of
his bike
i'm writing a book about skull and bones
i add
good
the officer who saw the movie furrows
his brow and shakes his head i can't
wait for all this crazy [ __ ] to be
exposed he says i hear they have
geronimo's head in there geronimo's
[ __ ] head
can that air on c-span
i thought it was amazing and kind of
funny that even the new haven police
department was pretty weirded out by
skull and bones
but what was even more enticing than
people insisting relentlessly on
skullenbones permitability was that i
found out that at least some of the
members of skull and bones themselves
seem to believe that they possess an
invincible sort of power
a couple of years ago i wrote an article
for the atlantic monthly about george w
bush and skull and bones after that
article came out i received a call at my
office at the new yorker from a man whom
i knew to be a member of skull and bones
and this is an excerpt from the book
about this conversation that we had
he scolded me for writing the article
writing that article was not an ethical
or honorable way to make a decent living
in journalism he condescended
and then asked me how much i had been
paid for the story
when i refused to answer he hung up
15 minutes later he called back
i have just gotten off the phone with
our people
here people i snickered yes our people
he told me that the society demanded to
know where i got my information
i've never been in the tomb and i did
nothing illegal in the process of
reporting this story i replied
well then you must have gotten something
from one of us
tell me whom you spoke to we just want
to talk to them he said
i don't reveal my sources
then he got angry he screamed at me for
a while about how dishonorable i was for
writing that article a lot of people are
very despondent over this he yelled 15
yale juniors are very very upset
i thanked him for telling me his
concerns
there are a lot of us at newspapers and
at political journalism institutions
across the country he coldly hissed good
luck with your career and he slammed
down the phone
another thing that interested me about
skull and bones was whether it has
retained any sort of influence in the
21st century as it did in the 20th
in the early 1900s president supreme
court chief justice and bonesman william
howard taft named at least two of his at
least two bonesmen
to his 11-man cabinet
in the mid-1900s secretary of war henry
stimson surrounded himself with bonesman
whom he then put in charge of the
deployment of the atomic bomb
in the late 1900s george bush as vice
president held skull bones reunions and
as president appointed several skull and
bones members to prestigious positions
and now
in 2002
one of the most fascinating and
surprising things i discovered in the
course of writing this book was that
president george w bush despite his
constant disparagement of yale hasn't
hesitated to turn to skull and bones
himself over and over and over again
here's a passage from secrets of the
tomb about bush and his relationship
with yale
george w bush is unmistakably vocal
about expressing his distance from and
disdain for the elite northeastern
connections that shaped his family's
political dynasty
after graduation in 1968 george w bush
didn't return to yale until 1991 for his
father's honorary degree ceremony and
even then grumbled because he felt the
university had taken way too long to
confer the degree
george w bush's biting dismissals have
been particularly aimed at yale
he has sneered at the intellectual
snobbery of his alma mater a place that
he has said epitomizes a certain east
coast attitude and an intellectual
arrogance he finds unappealing
he has said that he wants to
get away from the snobs that people at
yale felt so intellectually superior and
so righteous
when he finally agreed to speak at yale
in 2001 he used the podium as an
opportunity to make fun of his yale
education
um i don't think that bush is the
purebred texan that he insists he is i
find bush's dichotomy fascinating and i
think his divided persona is sort of
neatly illustrated in where his twin
daughters are at school one of course is
at the university of texas but the other
one is here at yale
so here's a little bit more about the
more hidden yale side of bush
when in 1971 bush was rejected from the
university of texas law school he did
precisely the opposite of what one would
expect from a man who says he has never
relied on his elite northeastern
connections
he called a bonesman
years after other bonesmen had given his
father and his grandfather their first
jobs out of college
robert h gao a bonesman who was in the
same class as bush's cousin ray walker
told the washington post that his
company wasn't looking for anybody at
the time but he hired bush anyway
in 1977 when bush formed his first
company an oil company he called arbusto
energy inc arbusto is spanish for bush
he once again sought the help of skull
and bones relying on his bones uncle
jonathan bush who ran the new york
investment firm j bush and company bush
quickly lined up 565 thousand dollars
from 28 investors one of them put
together 172 550
bonesman william h draper
the wife of federal express ceo
frederick smith a bonesman chaired a one
hundred thousand dollar goal fundraiser
for bush in tennessee
in october of 2000 bonesman stephen
adams who owned adam's outdoor
advertising agency spent one million
dollars on billboard ads for bush
i just contributed because i liked him
adams explained to me
but when i asked adams admitted that he
hasn't ever met bush in person
instead he agreed that he simply had an
affinity for all bonesmen just because
they are members of skull and bones and
as he put it shared that common
experience
loyal bonesman bush returned the favors
in 1984 he jetted to nashville to a
company on a seven city tour gop senate
nominee and current knoxville mayor
victor ashe bones 1967.
while on the tour bush spoke devotedly
about his father to boost ash's gop ties
against an opponent who would later
become much more familiar al gore
also like his father george w bush has
used his presidential power to reward
his fellow bonesmen
one of the first social gatherings
possibly the first that george w bush
had at the white house after his
inauguration was a reunion of his 1968
skull bones class
in november 2001 bush appointed a member
of skull bones as general counsel of the
new federal office of homeland security
and a senior associate counsel to the
president for national security
bonesman frederick smith was reportedly
bush's top choice for secretary of
defense before he had to withdraw from
consideration for health reasons and
bush has also appointed many other
members of skull and bones to
prestigious positions in his
administration including an assistant
attorney general and an adviser to the
secretary of defense
think that george w bush exemplifies the
major paradox of skull and bones which
is that the society on one hand wants to
be secret and invisible but on the other
hand it wants to flaunt its power and
prestige
in his autobiography george w bush
mentions skull and bones only once he
writes
my senior year i joined skull and bones
a secret society so secret i can't say
anything more
it's as if he wants to stamp it on his
resume for us and then gloat that it's
something that we aren't privileged
enough to know anything more about
and finally the aspect about skull and
bones that i find most intriguing is the
relationships between the myths and the
realities of the society
the introduction to skull and bones
which is called the legend of skull and
bones weaves many of the rumors i've
heard and read about the society some of
them are true
some aren't but many of them are merely
exaggerations of reality
for example one of the most scandalous
rumors of skull and bones which some of
you may have heard by now is that
during initiation the neophytes must lie
naked in a coffin and masturbate while
recounting their entire sexual history
to the rest of the members um
this is a rumor that has become so
prevalent that some foreign reporters
i've seen have wondered seriously in
print with some consternation whether
our esteemed presidents bush have
engaged in that honorable activity
as you can read in the chapter on
initiation they probably didn't do that
however sexual history is a crucial part
of skull and bones
during the yale seniors year in skull
and bones there are 15 yale seniors and
they're known within the society as
knights
each night has an evening devoted to him
this probably goes from september to
october and during that evening the
night must stand in front of a painting
of a woman which the society refers to
as connubial bliss they also refer to
this activity as conunubialplus bliss
and before 1991 when women were admitted
they referred to all women everywhere as
connubial bliss anyway they must stand
in front of this painting and they're in
front of the other 14 members they
really will recount their entire sexual
history from the beginning to the end
and
this is supposed to be an activity that
takes anywhere from one to three hours
um i apologize to the yale men who are
there but i think sometimes the length
of the activity
depends on how much they feel like
making up that evening
another myth is that members of skull
and bones must leave the room
immediately if an outsider says either
skull and bones or 322
this rumor caused reporters on the 1988
campaign trail of george bush to wonder
somewhat giddily whether
what would happen if at a press
conference one of them suddenly shouted
skull and bones if george bush would
suddenly hop up from behind the podium
and go dashing out of the room
he wouldn't have not in 1988 but that
was a rule that was in effect until
about the mid-20th century
in secrets of the tomb i also of course
explore some of the more sinister rumors
about the secret society such as uh
whether the bonesmen were in league with
hitler whether they played any part in
choreographing the bay of pigs invasion
and whether they really do have any
relationship to a secret world
government
but in any case um the public's constant
shifting between reality and myth is
really how skull and bones retains its
mystique even now even in 21st century
america
in secrets of the tomb my aim was to
illustrate the truth behind the secret
society and as the book begins
if this truth does not contain all of
the conspiratorial elements that the
skull and bones legend projects it is
perhaps all the more interesting for
that fact
the story of skull and bones is not just
the story of a remarkable secret society
but a remarkable society of secrets some
with basis in truth some nothing but fog
much of the way we understand the world
of power involves myriad assumptions of
connection and control of cause and
effect and of coincidence that surely
cannot be
coincidence thank you very much for
coming
[Applause]
usually there are questions after i'm
finished i'm happy to answer them yes hi
uh
oh great
uh i have a question uh on behalf of a
friend of mine
he was uh
talking about the uh
ron rosenbaum videotape and says that
the smoking gun that you're all wet is
because they've is that they've uh
gotten an audio tape from another year
with a similar parody initiation
now it just seems uh
to me that the the parody might be just
as much of a
uh tradition as the real initiation
could could you comment on this
uh let's see what can i say about this
um
i can say that from what i know about
secret society initiations um from what
the more than 100 bonesmen with whom i
spoke
have told me and these are men who i did
trust and and still do
that
i do not believe that what was on that
videotape is the skull and bones
initiation and there's more about it in
the book in fact i have a chapter in the
book about initiation where you can
actually read from the skull and bone
script and i think i'll leave that
answer there
sure yes
i would like to ask you miss
if you
dislike this group
do you dislike them
that's a blunt question
um
i wouldn't say i dislike the group um i
treat them as a subject of an
investigative journalistic exploration
i think that the problem with skull and
bones is that it has people in positions
of influence throughout the country
these these members have included the
president of the united states supreme
court chief chief justices business
tycoons cia officials uh people running
many aspects of american society and i
don't believe that these are people who
reflect the rest of american life
i don't dislike the members of skull and
bones personally i think i dislike
the purpose of the society which is
really to propel their own members to
positions of prominence and then help
other members get to those positions as
well
yes
hello
well that leads me to ask then what are
some of the criteria that
the
society makes in choosing the juniors to
to join the next year
did everybody is everybody hearing the
questions okay
okay this question was about what are
the criteria used to determine which
juniors skull and bones will tap for
membership
historically skull and bones would tap
basically white wealthy males that fell
within the religious parameters that
they dictated at the time
now that's changed
skull and bones like to say likes to say
that it taps people who reflect yale and
i think they've done a good job toward
moving toward that especially since 1991
when they finally agreed to let women in
and i can talk more about that if
anybody's interested
i think the criteria now is basically
success of course legacy plays a part it
always has look at george w bush
i think the criteria now is really more
that if they think that a member is
prominent on campus in whatever aspect
of campus life if they think that a
candidate is going to be successful
later in life and bring that sort of
honor and intrigue back onto the secret
society and perpetuate the society's
lore i think that's probably the best
determination
my question is if this society is so
secretive and hush-hush
what was some of the motivations for all
these people to come and speak to you
and finally break their silence about
society sure um the question was
basically if this is such a secret
society why they talk to me which is an
excellent question
i think they spoke to me for several
reasons and you know more than 100 spoke
to me but probably twice that many hung
up on me um so they weren't all that
pleased all of them to speak with me but
the ones that were
one reason is that they know that i went
to yale they know that i could put into
context what they were telling me in
their interviews this was also a time i
started about three years ago when that
movie the skulls came out i don't know
how many of you saw it but it basically
portrayed it portrayed skull bones as
the most dastardly organization on the
planet um
secret society people thought it was a
pretty funny movie actually
but
some members of skull bones are tired of
this sort of mysterious code of secrecy
to which they're expected to adhere
they're tired of being associated with
nazis being associated with malicious
organizations and some of them are very
pleased that i was going to write a book
to tell the truth about the secret
society is to show how they started at
yale um how they grew why at yale and
where they're going and where they've
been some of them liked that very much
um
others really were just exhausted with
being associated with with evil groups
and
i think another reason they spoke with
me um is because as a member of a secret
society myself
they felt that i was not going to paint
the kind of picture of skull and bones
that
a conspiracy theorist might paint or
that a movie like the skulls might paint
as well
yes
did you find any connections between
skull and bones and
other similar groups such as the
bohemian grove
the question is whether i discovered any
connections between skull and bones and
other secret groups such as bohemian
grove
i do not believe that there are any
direct organizational links between
skull and bones and other secret groups
however there are members in there are
overlaps in members between skull and
bones and say bohemian grove or
the council on foreign relations or the
trilateral commission for example one
very prominent member of skull and bones
winston lord who
whom the bush
the reagan bush administration appointed
as an ambassador to china he was also
the president of the council on foreign
relations so you will see some overlap
but i wouldn't stretch it as far to say
that these groups work in sync
this organization
the skull and bones
their location
they are at the virtual epicenter
geographical epicenter of the yale
campus
um
yale
as a school i've never gone to yale
i went to a neighboring college
um
yale has always been a school that
primarily
has produced
businessmen and lawyers
these businessmen and lawyers go into
not just small businesses but big
businesses
and into government
um
it's that kind of school it is basically
a masonic type of school
uh has a masonic type of emphasis
it has had a masonic type of emphasis
this
organization seems to be a
very much a masonic type of organization
is anything
wrong with that
i mean
they're
they give a
certain emphasis to the college
they set the tone
for the college
uh they have other organizations here
but
this particular group seems to um
be at the epicenter in more ways than
one
uh
is that so terrible
okay the question i think is whether
skull and bones is is a bad thing uh
whether it's so terrible that they have
all of these rituals
um
i think i'll just say i find it
intriguing skull and bones
engages in rituals that have been the
same rituals since 1832 that's partly
how
they lure their their members how they
get them to
to stay with the society and participate
in these sometimes strange rituals
throughout the year because the members
know that this is something that george
bush did this is something that william
howard taft did this is something that's
been done every year in this
organization since 1832.
does that reflect yale yes it does skull
and bones is really the the epitome of
yale
yale likes to live in the past in fact
yale has instead of
fixing broken windows instead of
replacing them it's sort of it likes to
patch them sometimes so they look old
and in the early 1900s
when yale was renovating the campus it
shows a particularly weathered quarry
from which to construct its buildings so
the campus would look older than it is
yale like skull and bones as an
institution stuck in the past i i think
that skull and bones is from an ivy
league that really doesn't exist anymore
did that start changing in 1991 when
they admitted women a little bit but the
rituals really haven't changed and i
don't believe they're going to
any other question
alexandra robbins is a yale graduate and
co-author of the new york times
bestseller quarter life crisis secrets
of the tomb is published by little brown
a division of the aol time warner book
group visit
twbookmark.com for more information
if you'd like a videotaped copy of the
programs you've been watching this
weekend or any weekend on book tv
call 1-877